let's talk about generational use of
words hmm jeepers that would be maybe 50
yeah maybe 40s 40s okay I don't know but
that ends up being an interesting thing
because as a guy with gray in my hair
you know one of the problems often is is
my vocabulary is different than current
you know 15 to 25 year old vocabulary
and so part of that is you kind of have
to remain a little current into what's
going on in the world and you know
listen to slang that there's there's two
theories on slang and one is to
basically keep current with what's how
people are speaking which whether that
is actually going down to the mall with
your two people go to a mall anymore
that's probably that's dated right there
that's a yes so but anyway go down to
wherever the young people go into your
skate park you know and record people
and figure out what the slang is or the
other way to do it is the clueless
version where you create your own slang
because that way if you create slang for
today for today's youth then that film
slang doesn't work in for tomorrow's
youth it's jeepers you know it's like
you know it doesn't work but clueless
decided that they were going to take
they were going to create their own
slang so that it would be even though it
doesn't really work cuz that's he's
totally Baldwin now has no meaning
whatsoever but basically they created
their own slang for that movie and by
creating their own slang they came up
with something that we hadn't heard
before so that also made it more
interesting dialogue but really you if
you're if you're a writer and you're
writing for today's audience you have to
sort of it still still know what today's
audience sounds like and that deals with
stories as well just the story concepts
because you know it's like I know a
writer who's my age who is still writing
movies for julie andrews and and that's
never going to happen you know it's like
you can write you can write for the past
in the past unless you have a time
machine you can't sell that script for
me I grew up watching 70s movies and
gritty 70s movies are great but I know
own a time machine I can't go if I wrote
one I can't really go back and sell it
so even though I still might write one
of those just for my own personal you
know those are tough sales there they do
every once awhile pop through and I
think part of that ends up being there
based on a novel so you lose it killing
me softly what the hell is the name of
the file know that there's a brad Pitt
movie oh my memories all gone but
there's like a seventh there was a
recent 70s film that was somehow made
today and it was a crime film it was
totally hit the gritty feel at the you
know the same sort of a 70s feel but
those are so few and far between writing
for the wrong time period is a mistake
you